hello everyone the first game option
from this match it doesn't really show
you how intense the match really was
since I decided to show you a bullet
game at this game here it's the first
game of the match and it's from the 5
minute plus 3 seconds increment time set
time format and it really shows how
strong Carlson is and what an endgame
magician he is how he really creates
opportunities out of basically nothing
in the description below I will put a
link from the official article from
chess calm
Peter Dodgers write wrote an excellent
article and the matches always and you
will find a lot of interesting things
about in the article for example I
didn't know that Nakamura was actually
playing from South Africa he's on a
short vacation there and he played this
match in front of a crowd of 150 people
and there's definitely a psychology
involved here since it's very different
to play from the comfort of your own
home then playing from a laptop in front
of a crowd of 150 people in South Africa
but you know that's how it is he decided
to do it so why not in this game this is
the first game like I said and Nakamura
has the white pieces and he opens with
the d4 Knight to f6 by Carlsen Bishop to
f4 b6 Knight to f3 and Bishop to b7 and
e3 you can see that Nakamura opens with
the London system and this is something
that's actually causing specialty and
well not just Carlson's pretty much
every player since Carlsen really
started playing this opening also
employs the the London system i i've
spoken to
yon almighty the other day and he said
that he also is now playing the london
system and that it's the best i haven't
really tried the london in any of my own
games but if it's that good all day I'll
definitely give it a try so he sings by
Carson h3 and the Bishop to d6 Carlsen
offers the exchange of the dark square
bishop and he allows nakamura to double
of his his pawns so nakamura captures
beat Bishop captures and e6c captures
and e6 and Knight B to D to cross and
castles Bishop to b3 + b5 now and the
idea of doubling of these pawns is that
it doesn't really harm
a wise idea in the London is definitely
you have to push either a four or c4 and
open up the position and it doesn't
really matter how you do this for
example this is just a silly variation
to show why the doubled pawns don't
really matter for example if you play
Queen e2 to prepare e4 let's say rook e8
and now you do push a four if there ever
is an exchange in the center for example
pawn captures Knight capture side
captures Bishop captures Bishop captures
and Queen captures now the other D pawn
is coming to d5 and black is black fixed
his pawn structure Queen has to go back
and it's a perfectly fine position for
black so the the double the D pawn
doesn't really come off as a weakness
here so c3 by nakamura we have d6 and
castles Bishop to a6 across that has to
figure out as he pretty much close the
lights of course he has to figure out
what to do with the light square Bishop
and Bishop to e6 seems like a reasonable
decision since the bishop on d3 is is a
very strong piece and this bishop on b7
isn't really doing that much nakamura
captures it
c4 was also an idea here but Nakamura
decides to capture it Bishop captures we
have nine characters and a for now
Knight to c6 c7 sorry Queen to e2 and h6
rook F 2 c1 Queen to d7 and c4 now
d captures on c4 rook captures on c4 and
rook a to c8 and rook a to c1
nakamura managed to double up on the C
file and it's it's not a a big advantage
but it's definitely something
Carlson plays Knight C to D 5 and here
Nakamura has a couple of options he
could either exchange both rooks and the
C file he could play something like b3
to kind of cement that rook on c4 but he
actually thinks over a minute here on
this move and in this position he plays
Knight to e1 and this isn't a bad move
or anything tonight can come to d3 it
will be very strong there but it allows
Carson this devious tactic of Knights
the before and it's not that night
before is that scary or winning or any
but you have to be very careful here you
can't capture tonight of course if you
capture tonight and real counters on c1
but after night the before probably the
best thing to do would be to exchange
rooks here rook captures rook captures
Queen captures and go for Queen C for
Queen captures Knight captures and it's
an equal end game pretty much
symmetrical on both players head two
nights you know you have to play this
but after this night to be four moved by
Carlsen nakamoto play Knight to d3 he
didn't want to go for any exchanges here
and this allows Carlsen a brilliant
maneuver cross in place rook captures on
c4 we have rook captures and now Knight
captures on v3 Queen captures and here
it comes
d5 and it was at this moment that
Nakamura knew that he messed something
up because now we have two options you
don't have to move the rook to keep
control of the C file with a move like
rope c3 Roxy to Roxy Wan or you have to
play rook the b4 if you want to keep
protecting this on the fender well so
far this rook is protecting the a4 pawn
the queen is attacking it if you move
the rook a queen grabs pawn your other
option is to play something like rook to
be four to keep protecting the pawn but
then rip the c8 now Carlson is
controlling the only open file on the
board and against cost and this position
is simply lost that rook is stranded
there and there is there is no plan for
white hear story after d5 Nakamura
decided to give up the pawn and to keep
the the C file rook the c1 Crossin grabs
the pawn of course Queen to c3 and queen
to be five preparing Queen to e2 to
infiltrate the position b3 would have
Queen to e2 and now Queen to c2 Nakamura
now prepares the tactic to exchange
Queens
a5 by Carson and now Knight to e4 this
allows this allows Nakamura to exchange
Queens what atactic Queen captures and
now we have this in-between move Knight
captures and f6g captures on f6 kind of
messing up Carson's pawn structure here
and now rough characters on c2 so now
it's a rook ending and the
is only a pawn up which usually you know
usually if someone's only opponent in a
rock ending you can draw this game but
this is cousin and cousin simply you
know destroys everyone in end games b5
by Carlson team to f1 Nakamura has to
get his King into the game and now rook
to a - rock - 8 kinky - we have eight
for now and here probably the best move
would be to capture capture and but it
doesn't really matter and Nakamura
pushes v4 across and pushes a three rook
to a two blocking the pawn and now rook
to a for now Carlson wants to grab the
be for pawn and give up the a3 pawn king
goes deeper into the position the rook
captures rook captures and now rook to
be - Nakamura has to go back with the
king
otherwise he's gonna lose all of his
King side pawns came to e1 and now
before we have rook to e8 check King to
g7 now rook to b7 you have to put your
rope behind the best bond this is just
how it is that's the rule h5 will have
g4 Nakamura wants to exchange as many
points as possible and course and of
course ignores this h4 King to f1 now we
have b3 kink the g2 rook to be one
pushing the pawn even further King f3
now II five King back to G - B - now
rook to be five but simple King to f8
now cousin wants to bring his own King
into the position of course this is a
standard theme in Rock endings
you can never capture up on like this
you have to always keep an eye on the
b-pawn otherwise you get rook to g1
check King captures and now you bring a
queen into the game
so after King to f8 look to b7 now King
to e8 g v EG after sandy for he captures
on d 4f captures and g5 and now Carson
is up two points this is completely
winning for Black Rock - bah-bah check
King to d7 and in this position Nakamura
resigned the game there's really nothing
he can do the King can simply waltz into
the position using any squares he wants
this game pretty much can't move
if the rook ever gets a chance to check
this king and this rook isn't on the B
file it's game over so pretty much the
rook is stuck watching the beep on and
the King can't really move so it would
be fairly easy for cousin to win this so
as you can see in this game it was a
it's it's how you play against the
London if you're if you're the strongest
player in the world obviously you just
wait you know your opponent to make a
simple simple inaccuracy and then take
advantage of that and it really shows
how Carson really needs just that one
little inaccuracy to create a wonderful
winning chances so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it like I said it
was the first game of the match and you
know Carson started off with a victory
and Nakamura did manage to equalize in a
couple of games in I think in Game three
but then Carlson really got a nice
winning streak so yeah as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon probably with another game from
this great speech Chess Championship
finals see you soon